Other than.
Hello, Andy.
Hi, good morning, Wayne.
Hello, Ben.
Goodnight.
I couldn't hear you clearly. Annie, are you able to hear him?
There might be some problem, even I could not hear clearly.
Correctly.
Yes.
Okay.
Okay, I hope you're doing well.
Sure, you too.
Yes.
Thank you.
All right, thank you. So let's get it started, Team.
Before I start with the call.
I hope when things went well in the month of March and you're doing well from health-wise and otherwise.
All is well, thanks.
Thank you. Is Jim traveling somewhere or visiting any client side? So should we should we be expecting him?
I.
I haven't talked to him at all today.
So, I suspect he is...
Is he doing something?
Okay, alright.
Okay, so well, so well, let's move on with the call. Andy, are you joining for the first time this call?
Yeah, let me give a brief introduction here.
Okay, so why don't you introduce? Yeah, absolutely. Thank you.
Evan, this is Andy and I've been working in ITBD by design since the last 11 years and recently moved to the customer experience team. And I'm here with the responsibility of customer experience manager to ensure that things are good and you're happy.
True.
Welcome to this call, Kevin. Would you like to say anything from your end?
Nope. Thank you everyone for joining in. Good morning, Jain.
Ben.
Yep, that's it. I hope everyone is doing well. Thank you, Gavin, Godya.
Thank you.
Thank you team for joining in and officially welcome to this call and happy Thursday everyone. So before taking much of your time, so let's get this rolling and review the PPT.
Let me know once my screen is visible to everyone.
Yeah, it'll be there on your screens in a few seconds.
Must be there by now.
Yes.
Excuse me.
The.
Thank Yu.
So, this is for the month of March, which we're doing in April, and agenda items are going to be the same. So, we have highlights, performance KP analysis, ITBD C set, US holiday schedule, yeah, by design, view forward with Dewer Technologies, and of course, recap, which I'll
also be sharing after this call via email. And I don't have to say it, but I always do as a virtual, so this is going to be, this needs to be an interactive session. So team, I mean, Wayne, Andy, Kevin, please feel free to chime in wherever you think you have, you know, you have observed something or you have some inputs or insights or feedback.
Thank you.
Moving on with the highlights, which I captured for the month of March. So great to see that. Alex continued to exceed his TRR, ticket resulted target, also in the month of March as well. And he also remained consistent in meeting his available target in this period.
And he depicted strong with his attendance in PTO. Why I'm covering this is because I saw that in the month of March, he did not plan a single, you know, PTO for himself, nor, I mean, I mean, we understand, we know that.
on schedule or sick leaves are not in our control, but it was good that he was he was 100% present apart from the holiday. And he's happy to be a part of the project work, Wayne. Thank you to you for assigning him some or
Making up a part of some projects.
So overall, anything from your end?
No.
Is it doing good?
Yep, everything is going great. Been having him do more service desk stuff, and he's been getting a little more variety lately.
So.
Okay.
That'll be great. I'm sure he'll be happy and I'll be happier too. Thank you. And of course, you and Jim would also be happy to give him some further workload as per his capability. Thank you. Moving on with performance analysis, and so you know that I'm including this slide as per
Jim's advice that he would like to see what he is doing when it comes to SOP world. So sharing last five months of data from November till March. And yeah, as we discussed previously, so he's consistent on working between 7:00 to 8:00 SOPs.
These or 6 to 8 SOPs in a month.
And yeah, and his time is also very adequate, not spending much time when more updates are not required to be done on the SOP. So only what is needed is spending that much of time. So that is from, if you see from.
November, only one hour and 15 minutes to one hour and 77. You know, I would say, I mean, this is as for the percentage. So 1.77, and in the month of March.
Yeah, so anything, if you think you know he needs to, he can do something more. I know we discussed last time as well. So major challenge that he experiences is, although this is a priority second, as you just, as you convert the last time, but anything.
But anyway, he can, you know, start picking up more SOPs. You know, he would like to know more, because the only challenge of what he's still experiencing is, you know, finding SOPs that require update.
Okay.
Thank you. Moving on with the billable utilization. So from the March 2nd till March 27th, his total utilization remain 100%. That does also cover the time wrap. However, to be very specific, billable time, which we more concentrate on, that remain
75 percent, 75.55 percent. And we see in all these four weeks in the month of March, he remained consistent, 76, 74, 75, 77, and non-available tasks, which does include many.
admin time, idle time, and other productive activities as well. So that remain consistent to 24, 26, 25, 23. So I think month on month he has been consistent on this. As we decided the last time, a few months ago, his billable target is 75, oh sorry, 70%, yeah.
70%, but he has exceeded that. Anytime you feel like you have some more to be put on his plate, he can do something more, just like you were adding him in some sort of project work and some of the break-fix activities. If those tasks...
May contribute some more time in this productivity. I think we can think of enhancing as, you know, billable target. So, as per activity standard, we think it needs to be 80%, but just because of less work.
Previously, we decided this to be between 70 to 75 percent. But please do consider it, depending on the work you have. OK.
Shiv.
Would you like to add anything, Wayne, on this?
No.
Okay, thank you.
In the month of March, his ticket resolve date from March 2nd to 27th.
remain 92.09%, so I'm glad that. So most of the part was the guardian stuff, which he handles a lot of tickets. So he's able to complete and resolve most of the tickets, you know, on a real-time basis, same day.
So in the month of February, although in both of these two months, he did exceed his target, which is supposed to be and which is 80%. And in February, he achieved 89.72%. And in the month of March, he achieved 92.09%.
So in blue and green bars, you will see number of tickets. He worked in blue bar and in green bar, number of tickets he resolved. So that remained, I mean, grew higher and higher from weeks first, second, and 3rd in the month of March. So third was the highest, which was from March 16th till
20th. And that week also, despite the fact he touched more number of tickets during that week, but it did not affect his ticket closure rate, that remained 92%. And yeah, so every week, 95, 91, 94, and 89. So.
I think if something more he can be, he can be added or be a part of, I do not think his ticket resulted would be impacted. So I propose, and I'm happy that you continue to add him in more other advanced tasks or project tasks.
In description, yeah, I also noticed that you know part Holly was the only day when he was out, otherwise he did not schedule any PTOs, so his attendance was 100%, which is why he worked more number of days in comparison in comparison to the month of February and subsequently.
He touched 46 tickets more in this period in the month of March, and which is why, and also not exactly, this is not directly proportionate to the number of tickets it works, and the ticket resolved it, but yeah, so I'm glad that he's able to complete.
the number of tickets he closed. That is 92.09%.
Anything you would like to add, Wayne?
Bill.
Okay, thank you.
And I truly appreciate fulfilling 100% CSAN for the month of March, you know, timely and really quickly this time. And I did share, I always share with Alex as soon as I hear that you filled the CSAN survey and he feels acknowledged. And yeah, this definitely encourages him to
To do more, and he feels himself to be to be a part of the DT family, so I truly appreciate that.
Moving on with IT by design services and events. We have touched upon this many times previously, so please do scan this QR code whenever you think any of these. This is just a quick highlight, but I mean, there's a lot more what can be explained when
when you schedule a call with our team. I pass this to Andy to touch upon these things. I know I've touched upon these topics previously as well. So Andy, if you have some more different insights, you can explain. Thank you.
I agree, Evan. When you might be already aware about our AI workshop which was held this week and which is concluded and it was really successful. MSPs really liked it. And next upcoming event is Build It and we'll have our AI workshop again with a schedule with it.
and we'll keep you posted with the information over emails.
Right.
Back to you, Evan. Thank you.
Thank you, Andy. And I know previously Jim did attend our AI accelerator. So when, you know, I know, you know, you're always learning new technology, especially SOC. So if you find these things are useful,
You know, I would request you to attend this session. Look, if Jim is busy, I mean, if you both can attend, that would be great. If Jim is occupied, please, you do attend. Thank you.
Shiv.
Okay, option holidays, so...
Alex has already consumed the first one, which is Holi, and the second one, which he is planning to take, that is in the month of October, the 20th, that is Jusera, the Indian festival, which can be marked on DT calendar. However, in case you have something, some requirements on that day, please do let us know.
And we can definitely speak to him if he can work on that day and take complimentary of the other day. And of course, as we have discussed already, so compulsory holidays, I'm sure, 8 compulsory holidays can be marked on the calendar. And yeah.
So you can let us know if his assistance or shift coverage may be required on that day and we can discuss with Alex. Thank you.
Therefore, I have not changed much, so my emphasis is going to remain on these first two things when it comes to Deirdre.
He needs to remain focused on SOP to strengthen documentation and knowledge sharing. And ITBD to support Alex to be consistent with his productivity and identify any areas where he can add value in your environment. And of course, we always like.
To organize collaborative activities, so that Alex, you know, should always feel that, I mean, it's not monotonous coming to your office every day, and we talk only work, work, and work, so...
Q2 or lunch, get dine together is still pending. So I'm planning, if not lunch this time, I'm planning a trip with my team. So if it would take, you know, a feasible PTO someday, or maybe I think a holiday is coming in the month of May.
So we can plan that day. So Alex and I, we have, and along with other team members, we are planning a trekking trip just to apprise you. So that, I mean, yeah, it's a 14 kilometers, a very rough elevated trek. And you know, after reaching that.
point, highest point. There's a beautiful lake out there and where most trekkers can go and spend good time. And yeah, some people meditate and or some just enjoy the vibe of mountains and cool breeze over there. This is what my plan is this time with the team.
Sounds fun.
Yeah, absolutely. So as far as the presentation is concerned, so that was all from my end. Same that we are open for discussion or any Q&A, anything that you have in your mind to be discussed on. Wayne, anything we would like to hear from you first.
I don't have anything this meeting, I guess.
Okay, as long as things are moving in a positive direction, in a right direction, I'm happy and contented, but please feel free to share. I mean, not just on this call, but otherwise as well, so that you will continue to, you know, sometime I know when we are busy doing the same thing.
Saying stuff on a daily basis, you know, we...
we often forget what else can be improved because we always must try to grow ourselves in all aspects. So anything that you think needs attention, where attention is not being given, please do let us know and we'll definitely work along. I mean, Alex and I, and
will move the needle to the right direction.
Sounds good.
Thank you, Andy, your coming, anything from your end?
Well, I just wanted to check. Come and go ahead, please.
No, but.
It is good.
Thank you. I just wanted to check with Wayne. Wayne, is there any opportunity to add more engineers or if you need any after hours or any services from us?
Not at this time.
Andy, I was about to answer before Wayne could. We have already spoken on that and so currently none, but soon, you know, after maybe a few months, maybe after mid Q2, we'll check with Wayne and Jim once again.
If there is any, when I will, I would also like to touch upon teams voice project that is with the professional services team. I know something was pending at your end, but is there anything? I know your schedule must really be busy. Do you want me to?
Yeah.
push things forward from my end if I can.
No, I'm I am the hold up on this, and...
I, it's maybe a week from now or so I'll be able to get back to it.
Mhm.
Okay.
We've got more projects going on right now than we've ever had, and we're training in new people.
Mhm.
It's been pretty crazy here.
Well, you're good, good, busy. So I really thank you and, you know, congratulate you on this new edition of projects. So please do let us know. I mean, if you're over occupied, do let us know. Unless, unlike, you know, what happened with the project task from both ends, you know, you're busy and sometimes our team, you know, earlier it.
It didn't respond timely, but do let us know where you need assistance. We do have team members who can support you in anything that you need assistance with.
Thank Yu.
Okay, thank you, team. So that was it for my end. We'll come up with more positive updates next time onwards. So in between, if you find or observe anything, please feel free to reach out and we'll definitely work along. Thank you for joining in and hope you all have a great day. Thank you.
Bye.
Thank you, everyone. Bye-bye.
Thank you.